So where are open chasing the scream is with this story that I think a lot of
people,
um,
think why the fuck is a book about the war on drugs starting like this?
And I think it tells you so much.
Um,
so in 1939 in a hotel in midtown Manhattan,
Billie holiday,
the great jazz singer walked on stage and she sang for the first time a song
that I'm sure all your listeners and viewers have heard.
It's a song called strange fruit,
writes a song against lynching.
It's the idea that,
uh,
in the south,
the bodies of African American men hang from the trees and they're like a kind
of strange fruit in the south,
right?
This is unbelievably challenging.
At that time,
the very few popular songs like that,
um,
and,
and to have an African American woman doing it was quite shocking,
right?
She wasn't even allowed to walk through the front door with that hotel.
They made her go through the service elevator.
She was African American.
And that night Billy holiday gets a warning from a man called Harry Anslinger
for the agents of a man called Harry Anslinger that basically says,
stop singing this song.
Right?
You think,
what's this got to do with the war on drugs?
So Harry Anslinger is a man.
Uh,
it was a government bureaucrat.
I think the most influential person no one's ever heard of is affected the lives
of loads of people listening to your show.
It's Harry Anslinger was a government bureaucrat who takes over the Department
of prohibition just as alcohol prohibition is ending.
So you've had this big war on alcohol.
It's been a shit show.
It's been a disaster.
And he takes it over and he wants to keep his government department going and he
invents the modern war on drugs is the first person to ever use the phrase war
on drugs.
And,
and he really builds this war on drugs around two intense hatreds he has.
And Billie holiday's,
the personification of both.
One was a really intense hatred of African Americans.
I mean,
he was regarded as a crazy racist in the 1920s which gives you a sense of how
racist he was.
He used the n word so often in official memos.
His own senator said it,
you'd have to resign.
That's how hardcore he was.
Right.
And he also had an intense hatred of people with addiction problems and Billie
holiday,
and she'd grown up on the streets of Baltimore,
part of Baltimore called pig town.
She,
when she was 10 she was horrific.
She was raped.
The man who raped her was sent to prison for a year and a half.
She was sent a reformatory for longer than he got right.
She,
she was tormented by the nuns there.
They said he was disobedient.
She brought it on herself.
They used to lock her in the dead bodies overnight to teach her a lesson.
She eventually ran away.
She tried to find her mother.
Her mother had gone to what's now called about Roosevelt island.
Now,
it wasn't called that.
Then when she was working as a prostitute and Billie holiday starts kind of
working in inverted commas next to her mother in this Brotha for when she's like
14.
So she's been raped by men for money night after night after night.
She's,
you know,
and when they,
the police rescue,
rescue break into the brothel,
they arrest her,
right and send it to prison.
Um,
so Billie holiday's trying to numb the grief and pain that comes from that.
Right?
So she starts out using loads of alcohol and then she's using loads of other
stuff as well,
mostly heroin.
And when she gets this warning from Harry Anslinger Sang,
stop singing this song,
Billie holiday's attitude is,
fuck you,
I'm an American citizen.
I'll sing what I fucking please.
Right?
And at that point,
Harry Anslinger resolves to destroy her.
The first man he sent to to tracker is a man called follow her around,
is guy called Jimmy Fletcher.
Harry Anslinger hated employing a white people.
Sorry,
I hated employing African Americans,
but you couldn't really send a white person into Harlem to follow Billie holiday
where it be kind of obvious,
say employed.
This African American guy called Jimmy Fletcher,
he just quit.
His job title was a bag man.
So he was given the job,
follow Billie holiday everywhere she goes,
befriend her,
document,
her druggies,
right.
He dances with her in nightclubs.
It gets to know her really well.
And Billie holiday was so amazing that Jimmy Fletcher fell in love with her and
his whole life,
he felt really ashamed of what he did.
He busts,
uh,
they,
when they come into searcher,
she,
uh,
makes him,
she pisses in front of him and says,
you can look in my purse so you can see I don't have anything here.
Um,
she's put on trial at the trial was called the United States versus Billie
holiday.
And she said that's how it fucking felt.
She sent to prison for 18 months.
She doesn't say a word in prison,
but what happened to her next I think is the cruelest thing she gets out of
prison.
Um,
and at that time to sing anywhere where they served alcohol,
you needed what was called a cabaret performer's license.
Um,
Anslinger make sure she doesn't get it.
So one of her friends,
your land up a van is also great jazz singer said to me,
what's the cruelest thing you can do to a person is to take away the thing they
love,
right?
They take away singing from Billie holiday.
So what we do to people with addiction problems all over the United States,
right?
We give them criminal records that make it much harder to do the things that are
meaningful to them by work.
For example.
Um,
so in that situation,
obviously Billie holiday relapses,
right?
She starts using a shit ton of heroin.
Again,
a one day in the early fifties,
she,
she collapses not far from where she first song strange fruit.
Um,
the first hospital won't even take her cause that cause she's got an addiction
problem.
They said we're not having a second hospital takes her,
but she says to her friend,
mainly dusty on the way in the Anslinger is men weren't done with her.
They were going to come from,
she said they're going to kill me in there.
Don't let them,
they're going to kill me.
She wasn't wrong.
So in the hospital she's diagnosed with advanced liver cancer,
um,
probably related to severe alcoholism.
Um,
and in the hospital she,
um,
she goes into heroin withdrawal,
so Maley for our managers to insist that she's giving methadone and she starts
to recover a bit,
cause her and was quite dangerous when you're weak,
right?
Like when you're old.
We've,
um,
Anslinger is men come,
they arrest her on her hospital bed.
They handcuffed her to the hospital.
But I interviewed the last person who was still alive.
You've been in that room or a man called Reverend Eugene calendar who'd been a
religious minister.
Um,
they handcuffed her to a hospital bed.
They don't let her friends and to see her,
they don't like or even have candies outside reverend calendar led protests with
signs saying let lady day live.
There were big protests.
They knew they were killing her.
Right.
Um,
then after 10 days they cut off the Methadone or she died the next day.
Her friend,
one of her friends told the BBC that she looked like she had been violently
wrenched from life.
Right?
There's loads of things about this storage to be made into a movie and Lee
Daniels is directing it.
There's so many things about this story that tell us what this war on drugs is
about,
right?
Firstly,
it's about,
um,
it's effect.
It's about shaming addicts in its effect as it makes attics worse,
right?
Is that where Billie holiday see that everywhere.
Secondly,
it's been insanely racist from the start,
right?
At the same time,
the Harry Anslinger found out Billy holiday had a heroin addiction.
He found out Judy Garland,
Dorothy from the wizard of Oz had a heroin addiction.
It may change as I watched the wizard of Oz when you know that,
um,
and he went to the studio and he advised,
he said to Judy Garland into the studio,
she should take longer vacations,
right?
Spot the difference with a white woman,
Judy Garland,
longer vacations with Billie holiday,
fucking destroy her,
right?
Uh,
if at one of the agents he sent to destroy her,
a man called George White,
who has got a tractor in the last days of their life,
we now know,
I mean he's literally a psychopath.
He was a hugely obese guys kind,
strange guy.
He infiltrated a Chinese drug gang when he wasn't Chinese the person to ever do
that.
But he,
um,
he boasted in his diary about murdering people,
about spiking women or raping them.
I mean,
these were really deranged people that were founded.
The,
the,
the drug will,
but the reason I say in relation to what we were just talking about is because
in this culture,
we tell only one heroic story about people with addiction problems and that's
what they sometimes recover from their addiction.
That is indeed a heroic story.
Everyone watching this has been,
who's managed to do that is a hero and I massively love congratulate them.
But that is not the only heroic story we should tell about people with addiction
problems.
Billie holiday never stopped using drugs.
She was still a fucking hero.
She any,
she never let these people stop her singing that song.
She would go to the places where you didn't have a license,
you'd go to the worst parts of the deep south.
She sang strange fruit,
they people threw bottles at her,
they stopped out cigarettes on her.
She never stopped singing that song.
Right.
And I think about Billie Holiday a lot,
and I think about,
you know,
all over the world,
every day people listen to Billie holiday and they feel stronger and all over
the world.
Every day we are still following the policies of Harry Anslinger and it makes us
weaker.
And this conflict that begins right at the start of the drug.
And I think if I'm honest,
I think this isn't an easy thing to say,
but I think one of the reasons why the debate about the drug wars so charged is
because it runs through the hearts of all of us,
right?
Anyone who's got someone they love,
he's got an addiction problem as I do.
There's a Harry Anslinger in your head,
right?
There's a bit of view that looks at them and thinks someone should just fucking
stop here.
Why are you doing this?
Someone should stop you doing this.
And then for most people,
there's another part that's like,
okay,
that anger isn't useful in most cases.
Um,
actually what you're doing this for a reason,
we need to understand those reasons.
We need to help you to change your life,
right?
But that conflict is,
is,
is very deep in us.
And Harry Anslinger the war he invented,
and we can talk about what he did with cannabis and loads of other things,
but because he invented the ban on cannabis that that war is,
is still playing out.
Does that make sense?
I know that was a long answer,
but that's all right.
No,
it does make sense.
And it's a horrific story about Billy all day.
And I had no idea that I'm Dorothy from the wizard of Oz was also addicted to
the Munchkins.
A lot of them as well.
Now,
Harry W W W why was Harry Anslinger is hate towards her so extreme.
So when he was a kid,
the book is called chasing the screen.
Cause when he was a kid,
he grew up in a place called Altoona in Pennsylvania.
And he lives in a farm house.
His Dad was actually a refugee from world refugee in a bit comes immigrant from
Switzerland.
Um,
and they grew up in this farm house.
And in the next farm house down there was a,
a um,
a farmer's wife.
You had an a heroin addiction or methods,
sorry,
morphine addiction would've been hiring them.
And Harry Anslinger had this really haunting memory of going to that house and
hearing this woman scream and scream and him being sent to take the horse and
cart,
think it was 11 or something being sent to take the horse and cart into town to
go to the pharmacy to get her the morphine and then bringing it back in her
scream,
stopping.
The lesson he took from that is these drugs are evil and we need to destroy
them,
especially later on.
He,
he was in Europe during the first world war and he had this very keen,
it was a diplomat and had this very keen sense that civilization was incredibly
fragile.
It could collapse at any moment,
that you only need a little bit of contamination and it would all go to shit.
Um,
and,
and so he,
yeah,
I call it chasing the screen.
Cause I think in a way what Harris thing is doing is like chasing the scream all
over the world.
And I felt like I was doing,
going to all these different places from the killing fields in Mexico to
Portugal.
And Switzerland was like following this scream as it kind of ricocheted around.
And actually how he made,
he thinks he's stopping these screams is actually creating far more screams in
their,
in their,
in their place.
Yeah.
But I still don't understand why he had this totally holiday so,
well she's an African American woman standing up to white supremacy who has an
addiction problem.
But the truth is what he did to Billie holiday is not pretty,
it's not,
this is what you did to African Americans and people with addiction problems.
Billie holiday just happens to be famous.
I'm telling her story,
but this is what he did to huge numbers of people,
right?
He wanted to destroy the whole jazz scene.
One of the amazing thing is spending time in his,
um,
archives in Penn state was seeing all these memos from,
uh,
his agents.
We said to them,
go to your local jazz club,
document the evil things that happening there and the things they wrote back.
I caught a hilarious,
right,
there's one agent who,
I forget where it was,
but he wrote back and was like,
um,
there was a popular jazz song at the time called,
uh,
that ocean ma'am,
and had a lyric that said,
when he gets the notion,
he thinks he can walk across the ocean and he's like,
there was going to be an epidemic of drowning across the United States as people
use cannabis because they're going to believe they can walk on water.
So he would,
he was like,
I been looked through the hilarious we were at,
he said,
uh,
you know,
he believed that when you smoke cannabis,
time slows down.
So a minute seems to last a thousand years.
Like these extraordinarily heightened,
crazy things that he would,
he would say.
And he actually latched.
So at that time when he first takes over what becomes the Federal Bureau of
narcotics,
cocaine and heroin just aren't very popular.
Right?
There's just not much of a water fight.
I mean they exist,
but they're not that popular that can find a small urban scenes kind of this was
more popular,
not as popular as it is now,
but an,
and he had previously said,
cannabis isn't harmful,
not bothered about it.
He suddenly,
when he cottons on that,
this is the way it's a big buildup.
His department,
he announces that cannabis is a phrase he used was the most evil drug in the
world.
He said when Frankenstein's monster bumps into a spliff on the staircase,
Frankenstein's monster dies of fright.
Like Lee's extraordinarily heightened claims.
Um,
and,
and any,
any issues,
charts trying to get support for a ban on cannabis.
And he latches onto one case in particular.
I some point,
cause I think we're hearing these again,
these things again now.
Um,
so a kid in Tampa,
Florida called Victor Lie Carter.
He was not so much kid 21 killed his entire family with an ax,
but should the mall and with the help of the Fox News of its time,
Hearst,
Hearst newspapers,
uh,
Anslinger announces this is what will happen if you use cannabis.
Literally,
you will kill your family with an ax,
right?
And this becomes a very famous story across the United States.
And Cannabis has banned in its wake.
Years later,
someone goes and checks the psychiatric files.
But until I kinda wasn't even evidence it'd be used cannabis,
right?
He had terrible problems with psychosis.
His family had been advised more than a year before that he should be
institutionalized.
And they refused.
They kept him at home.
And this tragedy ensued.
We're hearing these,
these scare stories again about,
about cannabis.
There something that Anslinger said that I think could be like the motto for the
entire drug war in the wake of the sec.
So Anslinger introduces this band in the u s he promises drugs will disappear,
right?
You will notice drugs did not disappear.
He starts to say,
well that's just cause evil foreign countries like Mexico are flooding our
country with drugs.
You'll notice that's come back as well.
Um,
so what we need to do is force all these other countries to band them as well,
and then they'll disappear.
So the u s in the wake of the Second World War where it has the power to do
that,
the world is in ruins.
Um,
and there's one point when he goes to the new United Nations and he's insisting
this happens and they're basically threatening people.
They're saying,
we'll cut off your foreign aid or you won't be allowed to sell goods to the US
market if you don't do this.
The ambassador from Thailand is like,
well,
you know,
it doesn't seem to work very well in your country.
We've actually got a long pattern of established drug use in,
in Thailand.
We don't really have many problems.
We don't want to do this.
And Anslinger said to her,
I said to him,
I've made up my mind,
don't try to confuse me with the facts.
And I always feel like that's the drug war right.
And made up my mind.
Don't try to confuse me with the facts.